وفي العاصمه الاوكرانيه قال الرئيس
الاوكراني
اقال ادوارد موس من منصب قائد القوات
المشتركه التي تشارك في قياده المعارك ضد
القوات الروسيه في شرق البلاد ولم يذكر
سببا للاقاله وفق ما نقلت وكاله الانباء
وكان موسكو يشغل منصبه منذ مارس اذار من
العام الماضي اي بعد وقت قصير من بدء حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
نظام الينا من كيف مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود ومن دنيتك مراسل الجزيره من درغام
يبدا معك حسان مسعود هل هناك اي معلومات
حول اقاله قائد القوات المشتركه
نعم بالفعل هو قرار رسمي صادر عن الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه
بمرسوم رئاسي وهو اقاله قائد القوات
المشتركه الاوكرانيه هذه
القياده كانت
تقوم باداره القوات من الجيش الاوكراني
والمتطوعين
والوحدات الدفاع
الميدانيه
والشعبيه في اوكرانيا كانت قد اسست في
بدايات الحرب وكان يقودها
القائد المقال صباح هذا اليوم وحتى هذه
اللحظه وحتى في المرسوم الرئاسي للرئيس
الاوكراني لم يتم ذكر الاسباب التي ادت
الى اقالته ولكن لم يتم ايضا اعلان قائد
بديل لقائد العمليات المشتركه الاوكرانيه
هذا ياتي في اطار سلسله من التغييرات التي
قامت بها القياده الاوكرانيه على المستوى
السياسي وعلى المستوى العسكري
والاستخباراتي وكذلك على مستوى ادارات
الادارات العسكريه للمقاطعات في عموم
البلاد وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تصدر اي
معلومات حول سبب هذه الاقاله او عن البديل
او عن الاسم ايضا المقترح ولكن سنتابع
خلال الساعات المقبله ولكن بكل الاحوال
كييف كانت قد شهدت الاسبوع الماضي
اسبوعا حافلا على المستوى السياسي لكنها
بدات هذا الاسبوع
بتوتر جديد على المستوى العسكري والامني
بعدما هاجمت 14
طائره مسيره انتحاريه من الشمال من جهه
حدود بيلاروسيا منطقه كييف اسقطت الدفاعات
الجويه تسع طائرات مسيره انتحاريه في سماء
العاصمه سمعت اصوات انفجارات وايضا
الدفاعات الجويه وهي تحاول اسقاطها لكن
طائرات استطاعت ان تصل الى اهدافها في
منطقه
غربيه اوكرانيا وادت الى مقتل شخص واصابه
اربعه اخرين وما زالت النيران مشتعله في
عدد من المباني في منطقه خمرانسكي غربيه
اوكرانيا الا ان ايضا التوترات كانت جنوبي
البلاد تحديدا في منطقه التي سمع فيها
صباح هذا اليوم ذوي انفجارات بالاضافه
ايضا الى قطع التيار الكهربائي عن منطقه
اوداسا جنوبا
تحسبا من اي هجوم يمكن ان يطال المنشات
البنيه التحتيه الخاصه بالطاقه في منطقه
اوديسا بعدما دوت سفارات الانذار في عموم
اوكرانيا المنغامي منذ رصدت هذا الصباح
الى الماضيه
نعم تحيه طيبه عبد الصمد
البخمه طبعا وتلك الجبهه المحتدمه تتصدر
المشهد هنا في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا في اقليم
دومباس طبعا الاخبار القادمه من هناك على
الاقل على لسان مستشار رئيس دونيسكا
الموالي لروسيا قال بان ان المعارك الان
بدات بدات تدور داخل ووسط مدينه
باخموت لكن لم يحدد المنطقه باعتبار ان
قوات فاجنر منذ تقريبا اكثر من شهر كانت
قد دخلت الى مدينه باخموت لكن من الجهه
الشرقيه والسيطره على شارع باتريس لومومبا
هذا الشارع الذي يقع على
الضحيه الغربيه الشرقيه عفوا من مدينه
ضخمه الان الحديث يجري عن تقدم قوات فاجنر
من وهي البلده التي تقع الى الشمال الغربي
من المدينه وكانت قد سيطرت عليها قبل
يومين باتجاه باك دانوفكا والسيطره على
هذه البلده
يعني فعليا قطع طريق الرابط بين ضخمه
وتشيلسيار المدينه المجاوره بعد ان كان
الطريق الاساسي الذي تستقبل من خلالها
القوات الاوكرانيه الدعم اللوجستي والذي
يربط بين ضخم
قد اعلنت في وقت سابق سيطرتها الناريه على
هذه الطريق وبالتالي تكون كل الطرق تقريبا
قد اصبحت غير امنه على الاقل يمكن القول
هكذا بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه وهذا ما
كان ايضا مسؤول هنا في السلطات ضمن
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في دونياس قد
اكده امس رئيس ومؤسس شركه فاغنر الروسيه
اليوم تحدث عن وصول الطلائع الاولى
لدبابات ليوبارد الى القوات الاوكرانيه
لكن قال بانها مازالت لم تستخدم ولم تدخل
هذه الدبابات الى المعركه والان هي موجوده
بحسب معلومات استخباراتيه كما قال في
مدينه
المجاوره في مدينه افديفكا القريبه
والمتاخمه لنا في دنيتك كان هناك قصف
متبادل لم يهدا منذ الساعات الاولى من
صباح اليوم فيما يدل على وجود معارك بين
الجانبين بعد طبعا الحديث عن تقدم للقوات
المواليه لروسيا من الناحيه الشماليه
في الاثناء دنيت كحيث نحن عبد الصمد ما
زالت تتعرض لقصف بين الفينه والاخرى اليوم
السلطات المواليه لروسيا هنا اعلنت سقوط
خمسه مدنيين جرحى في قصف تعرضت له احياء
في شمال وفي غرب مدينه دانياسك بالاضافه
الى بلدات تقع قربه خط الجبهه حول مدينه
شكرا لك ايمن الغامدي امين عفوا مراسله
الجزيره
حسان مسعود